madame monsieur bonsoir voici les titres
que nous allons développer dans cette
édition la mobilisation de l'aide
humanitaire pour venir en aide aux flots
de réfugiés du kosovo
un pont aérien international avec
l'arrivée d'appareils français en
albanie les camps de fortune installés
en macédoine
la décision des pays de l'alliance
d'accueillir temporairement de leur pays
des réfugiés sur place au poste
frontière avec le kosovo nos envoyés
spéciaux
jérôme ni benoît duquesne et à tirana
bertrand cocq à chamonix en ce dimanche
de pâques cérémonie oecuménique en
mémoire des victimes de la catastrophe
du tunnel du mont blanc
et puis du tennis avec la france qui
vient de se qualifier en quarts de
finale de la coupe davis devant les pays
bas un parcours sans faute pour cédric
pioline qui additionne les performances
depuis vendredi dans le conflit en
yougoslavie aujourd'hui la préoccupation
majeure de la communauté internationale
se résume en un mot venir en aide coûte
que coûte d'assez dizaines de milliers
de réfugiés
les pays de l'alliance se disent prêts
ce soir accueillir temporairement chez
eux un certain nombre de ces kosovars
chassé par la force
nous y reviendrons mais voyons d'abord
les premiers effets de cette aide
d'urgence qui s'installe difficilement
macédoine
ici et là des camps de fortune en nombre
largement insuffisant face à l'extrême
détresse de ces femmes de ses enfants de
ces vieillards épuisé qu'ont rencontré
jérôme bunny et andré sera prisonnier
dans ce chan il essaie en vain de
communiquer à distance
en attendant que les militaires
macédonien le laisse passer
c'est une ville de toile qui s'est
installé depuis jeudi sur cette
frontière entre le kosovo et la
macédoine
les réfugiés ne peuvent pas c'est qu'au
compte gouttes les morts d'épuisement se
comptent par dizaines
ceux qui ont la force d'affronter le
voyage en car aurait tort de croire
qu'il y aille au bout la liberté les
autorités macédoniennes ont maintenant
canaliser le flux des réfugiés vers des
camps de transit ou leurs attentes va se
poursuivre derrière les barbelés
coupé de tout loin des leurs cousins ou
de leurs amis albanais de macédoine ils
sont 2500 dans ce camp de radoub chat
2500 indésirables que les autorités
macédoniennes voudrait voir quitter le
pays le plus vite possible
il se prépare à une longue errance alors
que leur kosovo s'enfonce dans la guerre
les enfants du village font ce qu'ils
peuvent pour leur venir en aide
nous sommes comme des indiens dans les
réserves d'amérique
un peu plus loin les réfugiés kosovars
se sont mêlés à des réfugiés de bosnie
parqués ici depuis quatre ans le monde
est venu trop tard il fallait venir il y
a dix ans un destin brisé
parmi des dizaines de milliers direct
jérôme ni à l'évidence les capacités de
ces camps sont presque dérisoire quelle
est la situation que vont devoir
affronter ses se réfugier dans les
heures les jours qui viennent et bien ce
qui se passe ici béatrice c'est que
jusqu'à présent c'est la solidarité
entre les albanais des deux côtés de la
frontière entre le kosovo et la
macédoine qui a joué un certain nombre
de réfugiés ont été accueillis chez des
amis ou même chez des gens qui ne
connaissaient pas dans les maisons mais
cette solidarité arrive à une certaine
saturation et puis en même temps les
autorités macédoniennes se sont arrangés
pour que tous ces réfugiés soit
canalisée car la hantise du pouvoir ici
c'est qu'il y ait un nombre trop
important d'albanais puisqu'il y à déjà
vous le savez une forte minorité
d'albane est ici en macédoine
alors il y à toute l'aide des troupes de
l'otan il ya l'aide des organisations
internationales mais pour les autorités
ici ça ne suffit pas et c'est pourquoi
elle apprécie le principe d'envoyer dans
d'autres pays d'europe ou du monde
notamment l'allemagne l'italie les états
unis
un certain nombre de ces réfugiés qui à
partir de ce soir ça devrait commencer
par la turquie vont être envoyés par le
pont aérien qui amène ici l'aide
humanitaire vers d'autres destinations
qui permettront aux autorités
macédoniennes de ne pas faire face à un
déséquilibre démographique trop
important merci jérôme le temps parlé
hier d'un véritable tremblement de terre
démographique
il convient de rappeler chaque jour
l'ampleur de l'exode des albanais du
kosovo
plus de trois cent cinquante mille
personnes ce matin et est parvenu à
quitter la province et à cet afflux est
cet appui se poursuit vers la macédoine
on recense en quinze mille réfugiés en
albanie 204 mille soit 34 mille
personnes de plus qui hier quant aux
réfugiés ayant gagné le monténégro il
serait 33000 soit un millier de plus que
la veille
derrière la froideur de ces chiffres
vous l'avez vu dans nos reportages c'est
la tragédie de tout un peuple
les premiers effets de l'aide
humanitaire en albanie commencent à
porter leurs fruits les appareils de
l'armée française ont fait leurs
premières rotations entre la capitale et
le nord du pays
comme l'ont constaté nos envoyés
spéciaux benoît duquesne et didier da
petit à petit les choses s'organisent
s'humanise bresse pour la première fois
les réfugiés du kosovo sont prises en
charge de la frontière pour les urgences
d'abord ceux qui arrivent épuisés après
deux ou trois jours de jeunes
pour les blessés aussi comme cette femme
touché par les éclats de mortier je ne
sais pas quoi dire on a beaucoup
souffert
ils nous ont chassés bombardé un pur est
en cours et vous ne savez pas ce qu'on a
souffert ce sont les serbes
ils nous ont chassés ils nous ont
bombardés
l'obus est tombé tout près de la maison
quand on était en train de partir
il ya eu deux blessés de mort et pour se
sauver
il a fallu laisser les corps se place si
la file d'attenté toujours la même à la
frontière le flou aussi important et les
témoignages aussi cru le soleil revenu
donne à cet exode des airs moins
tragique
et puis il ya les premières
distributions de couverture d'eau de
nourriture
les petits riens sur une détresse aussi
grande mais des gestes d'humanité
après tant de barbarie ce sont des
biscuits protéinés vous en donner la
moitié d'un aux enfants et entier aux
adultes y tenait
preuve que les choses s'améliorent les
premières personnalités font leur
apparition sur le terrain pour pouvoir
constater de leurs yeux ce qu'elles ont
vu à la télé un peu plus loin ce sont
les premiers hélicoptères français
prémices d'un pont aérien qui déposent
leur lot de rations et de vivre mais ils
ne feront que deux rotations le
carburant est trop rare à tirana et puis
il ya ce camp installé en deux jours par
la sécurité civile italienne
un camp inauguré en grande pompe par le
premier ministre italien et son collègue
albanais et qui pourra accueillir 3000
personnes d'ici un jour ou deux des
frontières de l'allemagne y sont
ouvertes pour tous les kosovars du clown
est des difficultés en ce moment ils
sont albanais et notre maison est là le
héros alors aux enchères ont soufflé que
la perspective d'un désastre humanitaire
s'écarte peu à peu savons-nous et tout
ce qui roule à peu près 150 camions et
bus qui arrivent pour pouvoir
transporter les gens vous dire aussi que
beaucoup de gens partent par leurs
propres moyens et que maintenant les
tracteurs vont pouvoir quartier beaucoup
plus facilement puisqu'il fait meilleur
de l'importance du flou qui arrive à
sion n'envisagez pas quand même de créer
un camp ici absolument
ce souk pas on ne verra pas un camp mais
un camp de transit car la migration
continue inexorable un flou qui se
répand sur toute l'albanie n'a du kanak
et 100 en albanie donc le pont
humanitaire international est à pied
d'oeuvre avec des rotations qui vont
s'accélérer
absolument c'est du moins ce qu'on
espère puisque je vous ne vous lisez
notre reportage il n'y a eu que deux
rotations d'hélicoptères français faute
de carburant suffisant à tirana et on
l'a aperçu aussi des américains sans
qu'on sache très bien si c'était les
premières troupes qui venaient en
quelque sorte hors fait rage les
premières troupes qui vont de l'otan qui
vont s'installer ici pour a pu apporter
aussi leur soutien logistique et d'après
les responsables ici du hr il y a eu au
cours de cette journée 150 tonnes de
nourritures diverses qui sont arrivés
sur la ville ça correspond environ au
besoin de la population et des réfugiés
pour deux jours dont vous voyez les
choses s'améliorent mais le problème de
base est toujours le même c'est être la
route qui va de tirana ici est très
mauvaise et très encombré de la
logistique sur le port de tirana est
défaillante et donc la nourriture a du
mal à parvenir et puis dans l'autre sens
cette route est trop encombré également
pour que le
flot des réfugiés qui arrivent ici
puissent écouler au même rythme que
celui auquel ils nous parvient par la
frontière c'est donc ce problème là
qu'il faut résoudre ces problèmes là qui
va s'étendre à l'ensemble de l'albanie
dans les jours qui viennent c'est à ce
problème la pondeuse vont devoir faire
face les olés sur l'humanitaire et puis
faut pas oublier qu'il y à d'autres
points de frontières on le voyait le
reportage d'hier pas très loin d'ici qui
sont encore plus difficiles d'accès ou
là l'aide n'est pas encore parvenu merci
benoît duquesne ces derniers jours dans
nos reportages vous avez pu donc voir
l'afflux massif de ces réfugiés
concentré au nord de l'albanie benoît en
parler un instant une situation
catastrophique
intenable et pour sortir de ce goulot
d'étranglement souvent aidés par les
autorités des centaines de réfugiés ont
tenté leur chance ailleurs
en prenant la route vers la capitale
tirana bertrand coq roger motte sur ce
nouveau chemin de l'exil
ils ont pris la route le matin ils ont
roulé cent kilomètres à l'intérieur de
l'albanie il est 3 heures de l'après
midi sur la route de l'exode les
réfugiés du kosovo pouce de vente eu le
poids de leurs s'ouvre le vieux raconte
comment les serbes sont venus chez lui
pour les chasser sa femme et ses enfants
ont eu si peur dit il que c'était comme
si la vie s'arrêter la femme décrit les
humiliations le départ sous la menace
des couteaux elle dit nous avons laissé
nos hommes au kosovo nos garçons nos
maris pour se battre mais qui leur
donnera à manger honte à vous les
européens qui tarde tant à nous aider on
a vu des vieux des femmes des enfants
tout un peuple en des routes coupées de
ses forces vives
comme ses deux jumeaux victor et
victoire ils ont un mois tout juste
il pleure dit leur mère ils pleurent
comme s'ils savaient déjà qu'ils n'ont
plus de pays
tirana la capitale albanaise est encore
à plus de 140 km vu l'état de la route
ils y seront à la nuit si on les laisse
entrer plus au sud et sous l'oeil
indifférent des policiers albanais c'est
un homme qui souffre en silence
d'autre part le police les serbes l'ont
arrosé d'essence avant de craquer une
allumette de son groupe
il est le seul survivant
ces heures de pâques qui s'égrènent
comme les kilomètres c'est la passion
des flammes du kosovo visage de piétât
âme de faire
survivre à cela nous rendra plus fort
sur cette maîtresse d'école
sur la plateforme du camion ils sont une
cinquantaine aucun homme en âge de se
battre à plus de 50 ans kemal
n'effrayait pas les serbes qui l'ont
laissé partir avec sa femme et ses trois
enfants
hier c'est une guerre d'animaux c'est
pas une guerre police serbe est venu
chez moi dans ma maison monde il faut
filer allait elle est partie en albanie
la nuit tombe quand le camion à bordeaux
faubourgs de tirana
les policiers en interdisent l'entrée
l'attenté longue
il fait froid et les ordres ne sont pas
claires vous n'allez plus à tirana non
non il ya trois mois on nous a dit la
police
comme souvent se présentent un bon
samaritain il dit qu'il les connaît se
propose de les héberger
encore quelques tours de roues dans la
nuit et au bout d'une route sans nom la
fin de l'état comment voyez vous
l'avenir
je ne sais pas à venir pour moi mais je
ne sais pas
ce soir pour kemal et les siens l'avenir
s'arrête au seuil d'une maison de hasard
demain est une autre vie et en direct à
tirana bertrand cocq à travers votre
reportage on comprend bien que ces
réfugiés ne pourront pas s'installer à
tirana l'objectif est donc de les aider
à trouver d'autres points de chute
oui bien sûr béatrice même s'il est
difficile de se faire une idée générale
de la situation ici en albanie faute de
chiffres de statistique
ce qui est évident c'est que les choses
sont tous les jours un petit peu plus
difficile pour les albanais dont les
autorités peinent à faire face à cet
afflux massif de réfugiés à cet afflux
continu
alors on ouvre des camps dans le nord du
pays benoît duquesne nous l'a dit mais
ce sont des des camps de transit les
gens n'y restent pas ils n'aspirent qu'à
quitter la région à descendre plus au
sud
vous avez vu dans le reportage comment
ces policiers albanais tenté d'interdire
aux réfugiés kosovars l'entrée de la
capitale tirana ils n'y parviennent pas
toujours
on a bien compris que le gouvernement
tenté de disperser ces réfugiés dans
l'ensemble du pays de désengorger le
nord du pays la province avec le que la
frontière avec le kosovo de soulager la
capitale mais les moyens manquent les
ordres ne suivent pas toujours
pour vous donner une idée de la
désorganisation qui règne ici figurez
vous que ce pont aérien dont on voit le
commencement ce pont aérien qui se met
petit à petit en place grâce aux
français notamment
et bien cet après-midi ils étaient déjà
interrompus faute de carburant il
n'avait plus d'essence à l'aéroport de
tirana pour mettre dans les avions dans
les hélicoptères alors évidemment dès
demain les français vont faire venir un
avion ravitailleur mais ça retarde
d'autant l'arrivée de l'aide aux
réfugiés qui s'agglutinent sur la
frontière dans des conditions de plus en
plus précaire
merci bertrand cocq de ces précisions je
vous le disais au début de ce journal
les pays de l'alliance ont donc décidé
pour la majorité d'entre eux
d'accueillir un certain nombre
d'albanais du kosovo
pour sa part la france indiqué tout à
l'heure qu'elle n'entendait pas
accueillir massivement des réfugiés
bernard lebrun
il ne fonctionne pas la nuit et de jour
sur les pistes il arrive que des
bicyclettes croiser les gros porteurs
américains sur l'aéroport de tirana le
ballet aérien de l'aide humanitaire
internationale s'intensifie au point de
saturer les deux uniques piste dont il
dispose alors à germer dans les cerveaux
des stratèges de l'otan à bruxelles
l'idée d'utiliser ses avions vides et de
leurs victuailles pour évacuer au plus
vite des réfugiés kosovars vers les pays
membres
plusieurs pays membres de l'alliance il
serait difficile de donner une liste
exhaustive sont prêts à accueillir des
réfugiés mais à titre provisoire
j'assiste su parce qu'il ne s'agit pas
de deux d'officialiser le nettoyage
éthique du précédente pelosse fitch mais
simplement de décharger un peu les pays
comme l'albanie la macédoine en tête
l'allemagne a proposé de recevoir 40
mille personnes la norvège 6000 le
canada 5000 même la grèce pourtant peu
amènes vis-à-vis de sa minorité
albanaise
mais membres de l'union européenne il
est vrai a promis de faire un geste en
accueillant cinq mille de ces réfugiés
idem pour la turquie et puis surprise
cet après midi madeleine albright a
annoncé que les états unis en recevrait
au moins 20 me côté français ce soir
l'initiative de l'otan a été plutôt
fraîchement accueilli pensons pas que ce
soit la priorité du moment
il ne faut pas que les aux rites et les
autorités de yougoslaves qui ont décidé
de terroriser ses populations du kosovo
pour les faire partir en masse puisse se
dire ça va on est tranquille parce
qu'ils sont dispatchés dans toute une
série de pays de la turquie aux états
unis en passant par l'europe
l'opération qui devait commencer dès
aujourd'hui au départ de skopje avec un
premier avion pour la turquie a
finalement été reporté mercredi à
bruxelles se réuniront les ministres de
l'intérieur des 15 pour déterminer au
préalable
combien d'albanais du kosovo peuvent
être accueillis dans chacun des pays
membres en direct de bruxelles devant le
siège de la tan jean marc et lowe's les
pays de l'alliance ont donc pris
l'engagement ce soir d'accueillir pour
la plupart des réfugiés du kosovo
quelle signification à doit-on donner à
ce geste à la fois humanitaire et
politique
oui certainement un geste humanitaire et
politique mais il faut bien comprendre
qu'il ne s'agit pas pour les pays de
l'alliance de faire en sorte que à coups
de poing et rien on avalise on accepte
l'expulsion massive de réfugiés du
kosovo
sur le plan humanitaire il s'agit
d'abord de faire part de faire face
parlons plus urgent en accueillant soit
en europe soit aux états unis ceux des
réfugiés que ni l'albanie la macédoine
on l'a vue n'ont actuellement non encore
les moyens d'aider ses moyens font
actuellement l'objet des efforts de
l'otan pour mobiliser des divers divers
canaux dead avec bien sûr les agences
des nations unies et les organisations
humanitaires alors sur le plan politique
le geste évidemment plus évident il
s'agit surtout de rassurer tous les pays
à la périphérie de la yougoslavie leur
faire comprendre qu'ils ne sont pas
seuls cela dit j'insiste il faut bien
comprendre que pour l'otan
la politique reste la même tous les
réfugiés du kosovo doit pouvoir rentrer
chez eux dans un environnement de
sécurité garantie par une force
internationale
et même si aujourd'hui à bruxelles ici
au siège de l'otan on a beaucoup parlé
tonnes de vivres et tonnes de
couvertures
les frappes aériennes continuent merci
jean marc il use
il y à quelques minutes comment c'est
l'hôtel matignon un conseil restreint
autour de lionel jospin hubert védrine
ministre des affaires étrangères celui
de la défense alain richard le
secrétaire d'état à la coopération
charles josselin et bernard kouchner une
réunion qui doit permettre de faire le
point sur les questions d'urgence
humanitaire au plan militaire maintenant
le temps l'avait annoncé pas de trêve
pascale en yougoslavie
une nouvelle alerte aérienne a été
déclenché en fin de matinée alors que
tout ce matin des bombardements ont
touché le centre de belgrade ses
environs et plusieurs autres villes de
serbie france à cornet belgrade
la nuit dernière une première explosion
au coeur même de la capitale yougoslave
les missiles de l'otan viennent de
toucher l'académie de police dans le
quartier de banny ça au sud-ouest de la
ville
après avoir bombardé la veille les
bâtiments du ministère d'hugo slave de
l'intérieur et le quartier général de la
police serbe
l'otan a frappé une nouvelle cible
symbolique qu'est ce qu'elles touchent
les forces de répression engagés dans le
nettoyage ethnique au kosovo
les chasseurs bombardiers de l'alliance
ont également attaqué des cibles civiles
cette centrale thermique qui assurait le
chauffage urbain d'une bonne partie de
belgrade a été mise hors d'usagé
d'après les comptes rendus de l'otan des
destructions qui vont commencer à
affecter la vie quotidienne des deux
millions et demi d'habitants de la
capitale du go slave déjà cinq cent
mille sont privés de chauffage et sa
sortie de l'otan ont également bombardé
cette raffinerie de pétrole à pancevo au
nord-ouest de belgrade
l'une des plus grandes du pays où se
trouve le terminal de l'oléoduc reliant
la côte adriatique au nord de la serbie
cette raffinerie revêtait une importance
vitale pour l'industrie nationale
une quatrième explosion que vous allez
voir filmé par la télévision yougoslave
est elle aussi provoqué par l'impact
d'un autre tir missile qui a touché les
piles du pont de novi sad à 70
kilomètres au nord de belgrade
un autre pont a également été détruit à
une cinquantaine de kilomètres plus à
l'ouest
pas de trêve pascale donc pour les
frappes de l'otan qui s'intensifient
même depuis le début de ce week-end
contre des installations vitales
militaire est désormais civils en serbie
une véritable course contre la montre
est engagée par l'otan
face à la politique de la terre brûlée
de slobodan milosevic au kosovo mais
l'alliance exclut toujours une
intervention terrestre sans un
cessez-le-feu approuvé au préalable par
belgrade
en attendant l'otan renforce son
dispositif en adriatique
avec l'arrivée de ce porte avions
américain theodore roosevelt à bord une
force de frappe de 50 avions et des
missiles de croisière tomahawk
bill clinton a également donné son feu
vert au déploiement dans les balkans des
hélicoptères apache de lutte anti char
et d'appui de troupes au sol ils
pourraient être engagées qu'aux boot
francfort aussi des forces aériennes de
bombardement
avec le départ aujourd'hui de ces f 117
furtifs américains de leurs bases du
nouveau mexique qui doivent rejoindre
dans la soirée la base alliée d'aviano
en italie
on monte des gros concerts de rock en
plein air semblables à ceux qui se
tiennent à belgrade pour protester
contre les frappes de l'otan
ce concert est placée sous haute
surveillance le monténégro est un état
démocratique dont le président ne suis
pas la ligne pro serbe de milosevic le
temps ces derniers jours disait craindre
un coup d'état du président serbe au
monténégro au kosovo maintenant depuis
le début des opérations alliées et en
l'absence de tout témoin occidentaux il
est extrêmement difficile voire
impossible de savoir avec certitude ce
qui se passe à pristina et à l'intérieur
même de la province en dehors des images
que fournit la télévision serbe et elle
seule éric meunier l'ordre règne au
kosovo voilà le message essentiel de ce
reportage présenté hier à la télévision
de service
beaucoup beaucoup de chars de l'armée
yougoslave et des soldats au moral
d'acier
aucune trace en revanche de 6 villes les
villages traversés semble totalement
vidées de leurs amis où sont ils la
question n'est pas posée au général de
corps d'armée de pristina qui visitent
justement 16 juillet vladimir lazarevic
serein présente ainsi les choses devant
la caméra
l'armée yougoslave a pour mission ici le
contrôle des frontières
hier les chiffres tard expression
péjorative pour désigner les albanais
ont attaqué son armée dans les collines
dans le secteur payable à nice le
général dénonce l'otan qui utilisent les
séparatistes de loups checa l'armée de
libération du kosovo comme d'un premier
échelon pour une éventuelle intervention
au sol mais le général lazarevic et
rassurant une opération de ratissage
sera menée dans l'aisne les unités du
corps d'armée de pristina peut empêcher
toute tentative d'intrusion venus de
l'étranger
pour ceux qui n'auraient toujours pas
compris le commentaire souligne encore
le bon moral des troupes que les
bombardements de l'otan qualifiée de
crime contre l'humanité n'ont pas réussi
et ne réussiront pas à ça plus jamais la
télévision serbe ne montre l'ennemi ni
les avions de l'otan
nil ou tchèques ou checa qui présentait
à la presse internationale dont le port
albanais
ou rech ces derniers renforts de jeunes
albanais recrutés parmi les réfugiés ou
venus d'allemagne ou de suisse
une armée très désorganisés mais pas des
fêtes selon l'otan une armée qui
continueraient à être bombardées au
kosovo malgré les efforts des alliés
pour faire taire artillerie et aviation
us
la chaîne de télévision britannique que
la bbc diffusait hier soir les premières
images d'un massacre attribué aux forces
serbes images rapportées par un réfugié
qui aurait tourné à l'aide d'une vidéo
amateur
l'auteur du film à expliquer dans
quelles circonstances ils avaient réussi
à faire sortir ce document mais ces
images sont à prendre avec précaution
les informations sont pour l'instant non
vérifiées tir et kurt et c'est avec ces
images que le grand journal de la bbc a
débuté tard pierrot soir quelques
précautions dans la voix du présentateur
bonsoir les premières preuves des
atrocités qu'ils sont censés être
commises par les serbes ont été obtenues
par une équipe de la bbc
il s'agit d'un film qui semble montrer
les conséquences d'une opération serbe
menée contre village avant de montrer
ses premières images d'envoyé spécial
explique qui est son informateur millan
bel annick et dans quelles circonstances
il a filmé lorsque les serres sont
arrivés lui a pu s'enfuir dans la
montagne n'est revenu que sept jours
plus tard pour découvrir et filmer les
hommes et les femmes ont été séparés les
femmes sont parties les hommes regroupés
et abattu d'une balle dans la tête
mylan bill anika aurait recensé une
centaine de corps identifié 26 d'entre
eux ils ont été tués un par un un groupe
de serbes se tenait sur la colline un
autre est descendu nos hommes ont été
capturés les serbes les ont tués les uns
après les autres
toutes les victimes sont de jeunes
hommes et est il membre de l'armée de
libération du kosovo
ils avaient tous mon âge personne
n'était membre de l'ue ces cas ils
étaient tous fermiers à la bbc il n'y a
pas eu d'hésitation pour diffuser ces
images on nous a expliqué que toutes les
précautions possibles contre une
éventuelle manipulation ont été pris sur
place
pour le ministre des affaires étrangères
britannique robin cook ces images ne
font que confirmer des informations
obtenues par ailleurs
ces gens ne sont pas morts dans une
bataille ils ont été tués de sang froid
et sont morts pour une seule raison il
n'était pas la bonne ethnie exactement
ce genre d'atrocité qui confiant le
besoin d'une action militaire
r et renforce notre résolution dans les
jambes ou jusqu'à ce que le kosovo soit
libéré et à l'abri d'un répression et la
presse britannique ce matin s'est dit
convaincu les photos tirées du film
s'étale sur toutes les unes
jeudi dernier nous vous montrions les
images de la rencontre entre slobodan
milosevic et le surf modérée des
albanais du kosovo ibrahim rugova depuis
ce jour aucune nouvelle ni du dirigeant
al banani de sa famille aujourd'hui le
temps a carrément évoqué l'idée d'une
manipulation médiatique orchestrée par
le président serbe
la preuve par l'image n'existe pas
isabelle steiss le cargo va est devenu
une arme dans la bataille de propagande
que se livrent l'otan et le président
milosevic
lors de sa conférence de presse
aujourd'hui à bruxelles le porte parole
de l'otan james chi affirme qu'ibrahim
rugova n'est pas libre de ses mouvements
sa maison de pristina dit il est occupé
par les forces de sécurité serbes sa
famille n'en n'occupe que le premier
étage ibrahim rugova doit se présenter à
la police plusieurs fois par l'otan qui
cite une source occidentale indique
également que ces images diffusées le
1er avril par la télévision serbe serait
en fait les archives d'une rencontre
filmée il ya plus de deux ans lors d'un
accord sur l'enseignement au kosovo
c'est parce que ces images présentées
par les serbes comme une réconciliation
politique en pleine guerre du kosovo ont
consterné l'occident qu'elle accrédite
la thèse d'une manipulation
archives ou poignées de mains imposer un
homme retenu en otage à cette mise en
scène
s'ajoutent selon l'otan des propos
déformés
ainsi lors de cette conférence de presse
tenue à pristina le 1er avril sous
contrôle de la police ferme
ibrahim rugova 10 et ont alors appelé à
l'arrêt des bombardements
il a seulement demandé que cesse la
violence dit aujourd'hui l'otan une
chose est sûre ce en dépit de leurs
demandes répétées aucun dirigeant en
occident n'a eu jusqu'à ce jour de
contact direct avec ibrahim rugova je
vous parlais il ya quelques instants de
la réunion qui se tient en ce moment
même à matignon lionel jospin vient de
déclarer qu'il juge fondamental que les
réfugiés
rentré ses voeux en italie maintenant
sur la base d'aviano la célébration des
fêtes de pâques malgré la situation de
crise en yougoslavie d'à côté
l'hostilité du prêtre de la petite ville
d'aviano de l'autre la détermination de
l'aumônier militaire allen salvan pacsés
pack vraiment pleine guerre
la petite chapelle de la base aérienne
d'aviano accueilli ce matin les
militaires que les opérations de
bombardement de la nuit intense n'ont
pas empêché de dormir
ils étaient peu nombreux en vérité sur
les 5700 sommes en service sur la base
qui en ce moment on s'en doute l'esprit
plus tourné vers le kosovo que vers
jérusalem et la résurrection du christ
peu nombreux visiblement exténué à
écouter un aumônier de choc
nous ne craignons aucun pouvoir force
opposition circonstance sous conditions
aucune personne aujourd'hui et demain
à trois kilomètres de là dans la petite
ville d'aviano c'était pâques aussi mais
la tonalité était bien diverses
le curé ici a déployé une banderole
demandant que les armes se taisent un
pacifiste convaincu que donne pier luigi
bien dans la tonalité est prestement et
en a pas c'est une bac qu'ont sanglante
et cette année nous sentons le poids de
cette tragédie de la guerre
je continue à croire qu'il y avait
d'autres chemins que nous pouvions
emprunter la route qui longe la base
aérienne a été encore aujourd'hui le
lieu privilégié de promenade pour les
habitants d'aviano attirés par le
spectacle de la guerre en direct en
réalité il n'y a guère eu d'opération
cet après midi au départ d'aviano mais
cette trêve inattendu semble plus due
aux conditions météo sur le kosovo coben
paroles de paix prononcée par le pape et
tous les curés d'italie dans son message
de pâques jean paul ii avant de donner
la bénédiction urbi et orbi à commenter
les événements yougoslavie devant
plusieurs dizaines de milliers de
pèlerins cette messe de pâques était
dédiée à la terre martyrisée du kosovo
caroline audrin
cette messe de pâques la dernière avant
le passage à l'an 2000 le pape jean paul
ii a voulu l'a consacré à la terre
martyrisée du kosovo devant les trente
mille pèlerins rassemblés sur le parvis
de la basilique saint pierre de rome
il a franchi une étape supplémentaire
dans l'activité diplomatique du
saint-siège dans son message de pâques
le saint père a conjuré les parties
concernées à arrêter de verser
cruellement le sens de l'homme comment
rester insensible s'est il exclamé
devant le flou douloureux d'hommes et de
femmes du kosovo qui frappent à nos
portes
implorant notre aide puis le pape s'est
adressé directement à belgrade à saintes
en ce jour si je me sens le devoir d'y
les mauls adressé un appel chargé de
tristesse à la autorise table aux
autorités de la république fédérale de
yougoslavie à winkel afin qu'elle permet
l'ouverture d'un couloir communautaire
nidal qui permettra d'apporter une aide
aux populations massées sur la frontière
du corps social cela venant des côtes
alors va pour des actions de solidarité
il ne peut exister de frontières puis le
saint-père a donné sa bénédiction
oublier torby traduisez à la ville et au
monde
fidèle à la tradition
il a souhaité bonne fête de pâques en 65
langues dont le serbe et l'albanais à
strasbourg pour la paire ne rock ce
défilé dans les rues de la ville environ
1300 personnes composée de deux tiers
des allemands de serbes de kurdes ont
protesté contre les interventions de
l'otan cette manifestation se déroule
chaque année à pâques elle avait cette
fois ci une résonance particulière avec
le conflit en yougoslavie dans
l'actualité de ce dimanche le
recueillement à chamonix pour une
cérémonie oecuménique à la mémoire des
victimes du tunnel du mont blanc vers
nous virginie fichet gilles perret sur
les cendres ils sont venus déposer leur
tristesse un geste symbolique porteurs
de toute l'émotion d'une vallée
traumatisés
une fois encore ce matin 250 personnes
environ sont montés jusqu'au tunnel
autour du prêtre du pasteur de chamonix
tous sont avant tout voulu témoigner
leur soutien aux familles durement
éprouvées
nous sommes là en cette fin de matinée
et dans le silence en france plus que le
réconfort les proches de certaines
victimes sont venus chercher le
commencement d'un long travail de deuil
défiant le tunnel de leur chagrin de
leur colère chela n monsieur après ces
personnes qui devait fermer ce tunnel
mais qui n'ont pas fermé pour pouvoir
l'argent monsieur dans le recueillement
les familles ont oublié un instant les
rancoeurs les questions responsable du
tunnel élus aux habitants pour tous seul
comptait aujourd'hui l'hommage aux
quarante victimes supplique -
responsable je me sens concerné quand
même ne pas avoir fait plus de
manifestations pour penser à la sécurité
c'est à tout ça je trouve que celle où
le ce qu'on paye mais il faut qu'on se
bouge et c'est peut-être une leçon qu'on
a reçu tous le sont très sévères
désormais il faudra vivre avec celui que
le prêtre de la paroisse qualifié
justement de tunnels tombeau quand on
reparle une nouvelle fois de la listeria
ces derniers jours faire taire fromage
de maroilles ont été retirés de la vente
suspectés d'être contaminés par la
bactérie aujourd'hui la fromagerie
incriminé conteste les analyses
reste maintenant pour les producteurs à
rassurer les consommateurs
ce ne sera pas chose facile c'est silas
des fromages sous haute surveillance
pour la deuxième fois en dix jours
un lot de maroilles de la fromagerie le
ciré roger dans l'aisne a été retiré de
la vente le lot numéro 18
les services vétérinaires ont détecté
des traces de la bactérie listeria
or la norme européenne de sortie d'usiné
clair l'objectif c'est zéro listeria par
25 grammes de produit nous savons que ce
projet a effectué d'énormes efforts tant
au niveau de sa structure de son
fonctionnement que dans ses analyses
maintenant
ces résultats là nous prouve que
il faut pousser les investigations peut
être un peu plus loin la direction de
l'usiné contestent ces résultats
elle considère que l'ensemble des
fromages au lait cru est pénalisé à tort
l'avocat du maroilles et depuis des
semaines bien d'autres hommages est ce
qui serait un petit peu dommage c'est
que le terme d'appellation d'origine
contrôlée deviennent l'appellation
d'origine controversée
les ventes de maroilles le cir et roger
sont donc en chute libre
même chose chez les camemberts le petit
produit dans le calvados
après le retrait d'un lot touchés par la
bactérie les ventes ont diminué de 50%
au camembert et totalement sain que
toute cette information a été produite
je ne dirais pas sans discernement mais
beaucoup trop rapidement laissant
vérification et que nous avons a atteint
un patrimoine que représente le terroir
la marque la qualité d'une manière à mon
avis un peu il réfléchit carliste et
rien ne veut pas dire listériose
c'est une maladie de plus en plus rare
grâce aux efforts des industriels
mais malgré tout elle tue encore deux
personnes en sont mortes récemment après
avoir mangé un autre fromage au lait cru
il s'agissait cette fois des poils en
début de semaine prochaine en seine
saint denis tous les matchs de football
seront suspendus cette décision fait
suite à des incidents des actes de
violences qui se sont déroulées sur les
stades de cette banlieue lors de
rencontres amateurs furan muller alizée
tina les équipes de seine-saint-denis
mise sur la touche
hier à créteil l'olympique de noisy le
sec en maillot rouge et blanc ne jouais
pas un match comme les
dès mardi ses équipes de juniors et
minimes seront privés terrain toutes les
compétitions départementales de cette
salle ni seront suspendus une décision
carton rouge du district pour dénoncer
les actes de violence dans les stades
depuis une dizaine d'années marcel
bourdin foulent les pelouses des
terrains de seine saint denis en tant
que président du district
cette décision il l'a prise car la
violence est devenue coutumière
je prends l'exemple de saint-ouen la
semaine dernière c'est un gardien de but
qui a été expulsé après son expulsion il
est allé chercher ses copains dans la
cité est sis à la cité qui a tout
dévasté sur le terrain
si nous avons suspendu donc la
compétition c'est pour faire réfléchir
pour ce soir jusqu'ici tout va bien
côté gradins une équipe de vigiles
encadre les supporteurs à l'extérieur
une dizaine de policiers patrouillent
pour assurer la sécurité
personne ne nie la violence dans les
stades mais pour les clubs comme pour
les supporteurs il y à d'autres moyens
de la stopper le souhaitions que les
matchs de jeunes se joue dimanche matin
pourquoi le dimanche matin parce que les
casseurs entre guillemets y dorment
l'homme dimanche matin alors qu'on
pourrait avoir effectivement des matches
qui se jouent dans la tranquillité on
pourra aussi responsabiliser les
dirigeants du club se trouve ça pas bien
parce que c'est il faut punir les
auteurs de ces actes sont très quand
même ce un peu lâche mais nous on n'a
rien fait quoi du foot nous voilà ce
week end à montreuil les équipes juniors
de seine-saint-denis s'affrontaient une
dernière fois avant la suspension
cette semaine les dirigeants sportifs se
réuniront pour trouver une solution
avant que tous les footballeurs de
banlieue ne rentrent au vestiaire à vars
maintenant partons à la découverte de
cette discipline de ce qui est extrême
cela s'appelle le kilomètre lancé
certains skieurs frôlait 250 km/heure
alexandre kara nathalie gallet
cette piste-là n'a pas de couleur c'est
le domaine sans limites d'une poignée
d'initiés des skieurs qui n'aime pas
faire durer le plaisir en une demi
journée ils ne font guère plus de deux
minutes de ce qu'ils leur univers c'est
la vitesse même le nom de l'épreuve va
vite qu'à elle pour kilomètre lancé
combien combien je fais 233 km heure
comme jeffrey hamilton ils sont une
centaine à s'adonner à ce sport un peu
fou ce petit monde ne vit que pour et
par la vitesse pour en gagner encore ils
ont inventé des accessoires pas vraiment
confort mais diablement efficace
protection dorsale qui a été rendue
obligatoire cette année en cas de chute
pour éviter les éventuels brûlots parce
que la combi est quand même assez ci ne
sachant si jamais testé mais je suis pas
pressé de tester les
non record du monde de la spécialité
frôle les 250 km/heure les meilleurs
sont américains français ou japonais
pour eux elle est toujours plus vite
c'est un jeu un peu comme une passion
gamins à 13 ans guillaume flirte avec
les 170 km/heure un jour peut être il
battra le record des grands pour lui
comme pour ses aînés difficile
d'expliquer une passion qui reste bien
mystérieuse pour le commun des mortels
on a tellement envie d'aller c'est la
passion c'est la seule chose que les
cabistes ont un faux pas expliqué il
faut le faire pour pour comprendre ce
qu'on ressent
tennis la coupe davis avec est la
qualification de la france pour les
quarts de finale la nouvelle très belle
performance de cédric pioline qui a
remporté le point décisif après avoir
vendredi battu polaris et gagner le
double hier qui scelle bertrand dr
grenier la douche on l'apprend 15 ans
dans les vestiges contraint et forcé ce
soir pioline la prise au champagne avec
tout le monde quelques minutes plus tôt
l'équipe était beaucoup moins détendu
une rencontre en coupe davis
ça tape toujours sur les nerfs cédric
pioline a tout de suite pris les choses
en main le français neutralisent cry
chèque et ses services volées premier
set 6 soit pour pioli deuxième manche
trahi sec se rebiffe lui aussi et
s'impose 6 3 le ton monte les balles
vont souvent égratignée les lignes dans
la chaleur des arènes pioline n'a pas
laissé respirer krajicek
le français remporte le troisième set
7-5 et le quatrième au tie break après
avoir été mené 5 3 à 2 la france est
qualifiée
forget peut enfin respirer toutes les
arènes s'anime jury n'a gagné ses trois
matchs tous les os sont dans le même
panier le week-end de pâques
c'est vrai que j'ai pris une semaine
une semaine complète donc je suis
vraiment très content le nouveau
capitaine forget réussi son baptême en
coupe davis
jérôme golmard n'aura pas à jouer le
match décisif
ils font quand même qu'il aille sur le
court et je suis brune
quand font que tu gagnes cyber mort a
finalement gagné la france s'impose 4
victoires à une
prochain adversaire le brésil en france
au mois de juillet on a déjà vu ça
quelque part
le traditionnel marathon de paris pour
cette 23e édition c'est le kenyan julius
ruto qui a remporté l'épreuve en deux
heures huit minutes et 10 secondes et
c'est un français qui tient la 6ème
place
elle a donc l'arrivée de genius après
notre journal france 2 diffusera ce soir
le film germinal de claude berri
germinal c'est également le nom de
l'association créée par l'équipe du film
à savoir renault miu miu gérard
depardieu et bien sûr claude berri cette
association qui est venu en aide aux
chômeurs de la région qui avait
participé au tournage
bilan quatre ans après marie hélène bono
jean-louis vous sert le bassin minier du
nord l'une des régions les plus touchées
par le chômage
après le tournage du film germinal pour
berry et son équipe ont créé une
association pour aider les personnes
sans emploi
grâce à cette initiative cent soixante
et une entreprises ont vu le jour en
quatre ans des commerces pour la plupart
c'est le cas de michel addona il était
au chômage depuis deux ans mais il avait
un étranger en tête et lobe maintenant
le matelas ou trois bières en face aux
verts ils remboursent 1250 francs par
mois à l'association son café c'est
toute sa vie
60 % de sa clientèle sont ses copains
ce qui est un autre exemple cette
confiserie au plaisir des enfants
ouverte il ya un an l'association
germinal a prêté 15000 francs à noël
chômeurs pendant trois ans il notait
tous les jours le nombre de personnes
qui passeraient devant chez lui
autant de clients potentiels c'était une
autre habitation au personnel et cette
pièce si c'était notre salon et pourquoi
vous avez eu envie d'ouvrir une
confiserie je voulais créer mon
entreprise y travailler pour moi même
tradition oblige noël vend des bonbons
de mineurs un goût d'autrefois pour ceux
qui ont travaillé au fond pendant plus
de trente ans hulot qui gît dépouille
il prônait et des moments comme ça c'est
tout même à bas et je vous dise une
tangente en vermois recours à
l'association a prêté 4 millions de
francs pour la réalisation de projets
identiques j'ai vu une petite bonne
femme là il ya quelques semaines qui
avec son mari son frère avait ouvert un
petit restaurant était folle de joie les
on ouvrir un second tout ça parce qu'on
lui avait avancé 40 mille francs
j'ai vu un boucher qui en était à sa
deuxième busherie dans ces sacs et c'est
bien c'est de voir la joie qu'on procure
faire bouger la région c'est aussi le
but de germinal qui attribue des
subventions à des initiatives locales
dans l'avesnois l'association océan
anime les villages une jeune
institutrice au chômage a trouvé un crs
et animations enfants que j'ai pas
trouvé d'emploi le sélectif pas pour le
moment mais ça me plaît de faire ce que
je fais en ce moment pour l'association
lutter contre la précarité et
l'exclusion dans cette région la
vocation de germinal et de favoriser les
initiatives individuelles porteuses
d'espoir c'est la fin de ce journal je
vous rappelle principal titre la
mobilisation de l'aide humanitaire pour
venir en aide aux flots de réfugiés du
kosovo
un pont aérien international avec
l'arrivée d'appareils français en
albanie les camps de fortune installés
en macédoine
la décision des pays de l'alliance
d'accueillir temporairement dans leur
pays des réfugiés dans un instant à la
météo nathalie rihouet 20h55 donc
germinal avec gérard depardieu et renou
une heure du matin le dernier journal
soros duprat de masse perd 5 ans dans
les 4 vérités
françoise laborde eux recevra le
théologien orthodoxe olivier clément à
20h vous retrouverez claude sérillon je
vous remercie de votre attention
excellente soirée français